[Music]
foreign
we saw a horrible scene it cannot be
described it's very sad they're all my
friends friends I eat and drink with at
the weekend they all had dreams they all
had families some were married some were
single
of course we will determine how the
explosion happened and whether there is
anyone responsible through
administrative and legal investigations
we no longer want to see deficiencies or
unnecessary risks in our minds
the site used to employ 6 000 workers
now the same production is carried out
by 700 workers we will see the same
things if there's no effective
investigation and inspection deterrent
penalties are required Mistakes by a
state company cannot be forgiven
foreign
[Music]